Speaker 1: Let's see, where are we going
next? Oh, remember, if you want to get on,
your name needs to be name and location or.
Location and name, however you want to do
it in whatever order you want to do it. Like, for
example, Conner from New Jersey is our next caller
today. Connor, what's going on?
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Hello.
Speaker 5: Oh, you already told us that it
has. Are you doing. Um, I. I have a question,
but I wanted to pass on words of affirmation.
For starters, please. Following you for a little
while now. Like, honestly, solidly since
the Trump arrest was announced and all that
you remember me calling in the day prior, I was
like, I don't think he's going to get arrested,
but you don't have to remember. Okay, My whole
point is I've been following you. And honestly,
I grew up in like a more Republican conservative
House, and I might have those views. Honestly,
I don't even know where I fall politically.
But listening to you, I just feel like you
are so well thought out. So your methodology
of breaking down issues is just so solid. And
I wish that there was more people that claim to be
conservative or Republican that could be so again,
well thought out. I mean, like you're
inspiring to me. Like, I hope that I could
help change the perspective on conservatism.
Speaker 1: Well, I appreciate that very much.
Speaker 5: You know, move the Republican
Party forward and help open discussion
and not have it be this closed sided
debate between the two parties. I mean,
I really think it's possible young people have
to say enough is enough. I mean, I'm not against
transpeople. I'm I support gay rights, but I
still call myself conservative. Really don't
even know what that means at this point. Yeah,
but all I know is I want change. I want people
to stop picking sides and actually have these
sides working together for a bipartisan solution.
Speaker 1: What issues are you conservative on?
Speaker 5: I don't really know. Honestly,
I think it's more so of just like how I
carry myself. Really. So I don't know. To
be fairly honest with you, I've just grown
up in an atmosphere that was like that and.
Speaker 1: Not really what it sounds like.
You're sort of conservative because of your.
Speaker 5: Conservative, but politically, I might
lean more Democrat or left, whatever you want to
call it. And honestly, I really wish that people
didn't see how I carried myself and thought that
was how I carried my political views. At the end
of the day, I find you really inspiring, and I
want to know how can you what can you suggest to
people like me who follow you and want to help
bring more discussion in the world, or at least in
the United States, when it comes to really stupid
issues that have been around since the sixties?
Speaker 1: Well, I think it's just engage and talk
to people and share your story and say, hey,
you know, I kind of defaulted to a particular
worldview just by virtue of where I was born.
But the more I examine a lot of these issues,
I come to, to realize maybe I was wrong about
some of these things. And I think that there's
it's really powerful to hear from people on one's
side, as trite as that may be, and say, Hey, yeah,
I am from the same place you are. I was raised
the same way, but I've been able to actually get
some distance and get some facts and I've revised
my view. You can do the same thing and there's no
shame in that. I think that can be very powerful.
Speaker 5: And I guess one thing I want to ask
you before you get some more people, David, is
do you like. Personally, I don't think I should
switch to becoming a Democrat. I think I should be
trying to help bring the Republican Party forward,
even if I don't vote Republican. I think the
people that I'm around, I should try to help
open their minds to these discussions and help
it not be so hard for people on the left if I
really empathize with both these positions.
Speaker 1: Yeah. That, you know, I don't
know that it really matters whether you're
registered one way or the other. I mean,
it's it's I don't think that that's
the most important thing one way or
the other. Your story is still the
same story regardless of, you know,
your party affiliation, I think.
Speaker 5: So just keep doing
me and hope to open more discussion.
Speaker 1: I guess that's what I would say.
Speaker 5: Thank you, David. Honestly,
you've been awesome to listen to
this the short while. All right.
Speaker 1: That's Bar and Connor
from Jersey. Great to hear from you. Very,
very interesting message, that's for sure.